все мои крутые менеджеры при первой
встрече всегда не нравились мне я ворую
деньги у своих лучших сотрудни ставлю
галочку не хочет расти люди как едят так
и работают чихнул под нож захро мал под
нож Вы всё-таки гуманисты да да друзья
Добрый день я давно хотел открыть
рубрику у себя на YouTube
канале рубрику посвящённую
беседам с очень интересными людьми Дело
в том что у меня есть рубрика гка Вы
наверное знаете где я сижу с пятью
другими предпринимателями мы обсуждаем
больше про бизнес или какие-то
актуальные темы но я хотел всегда иметь
рубрику где я мог бы поговорить один на
один с интересным для меня человеком и
вот Пользуясь случаем Я как раз сейчас
нахожусь в семейном отпуске на Западном
побережье недалеко от сан-франциско А в
частности в городе монтерей и меня
пригласил сюда Владимир Сидоренко
сегодняшний мой собеседник это человек
основатель компании перформия человек
который специализируется на человеческих
взаимоотношениях на найме людей
а в семейных отношениях и так далее но
для меня он интересен больше не как
специалист по найму по кадровым вопросам
или по семейным вопросам А как человек
умный с которым интересно поговорить на
разные темы и вот Пользуясь случаем мы
нашли такую студию она очень уютная
хорошая студия ребята нам организовали
Большое спасибо и я хотел бы поговорить
сегодня о нескольких таких больших темах
первая тема - это в целом об Америке что
здесь происходит какой менталитет какие
здесь люди второе - это бизнес Что это
всё-таки Это бизнес - это инструменты
это мышление или это люди а третье Я
хотел бы поговорить о том о новых
технологиях которые угрожают Мы все
знаем и рабочим местам и самое главное
угрожает на морали и нашим
взаимоотношениям как новые технологии
могут повлиять на то как мы общаемся
друг с другом и вот обо всех этих темах
Я сегодня хотел бы поговорить с
Владимиром Сидоренко представляю Вам
своего собеседника очень интересный
человек Володя
поприветствуйте Владимир Сидоренко он
живёт здесь уже Сколько лет вы живёте ну
без вые уже 5 лет 5 ле семьёй Да но
туда-сюда ездили мы 25 лет уже можно
сказать точно не Турист Ну наверное я Я
в Америке Турист Володя уже точно не
Турист как говорят же не путайте туризм
с иммиграции Да и я уверен Володя уже
проникся внутренним менталитетом или то
что на английском языке Ещё говорят Зайд
Гаст или вот этот контекст в котором
живёт американское общество а
и многие люди особенно со стороны
особенно со стран СНГ там русскоязычного
пространство каждый год я слышу какие-то
прогнозы Америке конец доллару конец вот
Вот она рухнет всё здесь у них всё плохо
и так далее и так далее Это бесконечная
тема в связи с этим мне вспоминаются
слова ворона бафт которой я говорил Ещё
давно никогда не ставьте ставки против
Америки и находясь здесь Я заметил такую
вещь что
да на самом деле Америка даёт очень
много самое главное она даёт свободу
благодаря которому люди творчески
раскрываются и вот эта творческая часть
людей самом деле драт всю экономику все
технологии и позволяет содержать на эти
налоги огромную армию так сказать не
продвинутых людей над которым мыру с
русско язычного пространства смеёмся что
они не знают географию не знают где
находится Казахстан Россия и так далее А
вот пообщавшись здесь с людьми Я понял
что мы-то им особо и не нужны потому что
у них достаточно своих внутренних
смыслов и того что они в этой ранет я
буквально
враз СМИ
очень много казахов которые занимаются
мунго и работают на
фурах и Вот ребята Они из п1 штата Ну 49
уже посмотрели Ну кроме Гавайев и Аляски
и я их же спрашиваю Ну как Америка где
там ну они там ярко выделяют там Алабама
там вот
эти Луизиана Ну чёрные штаты
и то что там там действительно гово люди
им вобще всё пофиг там до Казахстана до
России там и так далее и так далее и я
здесь начинаю чувствовать что вот Даже
несмотря на то что не так долго Я в
Америке здесь Но общаясь вот с такими
людьми и с американцами тоже я понимаю
действительно у них сама система она
смыслообразующий
просто говорит А почему говорит русские
хотят на нас напасть
А ну на что я сказал Вы знаете но они
думают что вы хотите на них напасть он
говорит Да кто мы что ли Да у нас
говорит у меня одна только задача Как
быстрее с работы выйти прийти домой
открыть пиво и смотреть матч по
телевизору Вот это говорит для меня
самое основное о чём я думаю мне не до
русских Я так понял вообще в целом в
Америке честно говоря не до русских и не
до казахов ни до кого они живут саку как
вот вы пожив уже здесь 5 лет в целом как
вы смотрите вот на американское общество
особенно в плане того что там вот
загнивает что им конец там насколько В
чём есть преимущество в их менталитете и
образ жизни по сравнению с нашим Да ну
во-первых хочу сказать что вот познание
американского общества Я вот недавно
буквально несколько лет назад одну вещь
осознал которую я не осознавал раньше то
есть тут есть какая глубина которая
требует погружения и познания это не то
что там всё просто раздва и поехали нет
плюс всё-таки американское общество если
я не ошибаюсь это там вране 300 млн
людей Ну то есть понятно что они все
разные как бы но вот если как бы
прокомментировать то что вы говорили то
конечно там насчёт нападать друг на
друга Это я давно уже понял что это там
сильный мир и всего просто какие-то свои
игры играют а люди ни на кого нападать
не собираются Вообще никогда если их
сильно Только не
провоцировать по поводу того что
американское общество загнивает думаю
что это тревоги слишком преувеличены Угу
И вообще американское общество Конечно
самодостаточное я вот думаю что вот Кто
делал американское общество вот
Конституцию Америки писали вот эти вот
все законодательные акты на основании
которых появилась вот эта система трёх
властей Угу я думаю это одни из умнейших
людей человечества делали вообще то есть
не за там республиканцы демократы там
это то там Ну есть всякие повороты в
разные стороны но сама система себя
корректирует балансирует и она конечно
вполне
устойчиво Да и что вот что касается
именно самих американцев то знаете вот
это вот понял пару лет назад когда мы
ездили в Вашингтон там паспорта
продлевать там надо было и погуляли вы
были в Вашингтоне в горо не в штате А в
городе Да вот вокруг этого озера где
здание Сената вот эти все монументы вот
этим великим президентом США там великим
людям Мар лю Кингу там этому президенту
и вот их цитаты в мраморе и вот когда я
там побывал и я несколько часов гулял
Ино что-то начало происходить я начал
что-то чувствовать и вот мне показалось
что я в какой-то степени понял
американцев и потом я делился этим своим
осознанием самими американцами и они
говорили Да точно это так и ты первый из
иностранцев кто нам это говорит и вот
что я понял что
про свободу Многие
говорят про свободу страны там про
свободу там от завоевателей там вот
Гонконг там отделился от Англии кто-то
отделяется от Китая там кто-то выходит
из-под России и так далее в
Америке к свободе подходит чуть
по-другому тут Свобода именно
индивидуума Угу и
она в бетоне в мраморе заик вот эти
вызывания которые вокруг этого озера на
этих моментах это свобода человека я вот
прям почувствовал что называется кожей
что если здесь будет кто-то слишком
сильно
попирать именно Свободы американцев то
Миллионы людей в мгновение Ока выйдут на
улицу с оружием
защищать именно не то что кто другая
страна пот Вот именно
правительство не пройдёт то есть вот
свобода именно людей и вот и вот вообще
вот с американцами они очень все ну
большинство из них по крайней мере очень
приветливые заботливые С уважением
относятся любят помочь но вот это вот
пространство своё они никогда Ну не
любят когда к ним вылезаешь без
приглашения и никогда в твоё
пространство не заходят они очень
вот Свободы слова и всего чего угодно и
вот тако как бы ментальная Свобода они
бы
очень позволят людям быть свободными
очень это цет и мне кажется вот на этом
стоит американское общество у них Видите
вот я в своё время когда работал в офисе
Зеленского Ну Саакашвили мы с партнёрами
были в офисе простых
решений я тогда ещё много раз говорил
разговаривал с депутатами украинскими
депутата знаете проблема вообще
постсоветских в том что
преувеличиваю значение свободы и при
этом мы как-то все умалчивает ветственно
А Мы все видим только одно Бока одну
сторону Свобода - это вот свобода - это
свобода ответственность как бы это
отдельно на самом деле это неразделимые
понятия здесь феномен американского
общества в том что люди очень сильно
борются за свою свободу и ограничителем
их Свободы является Свобода других людей
и они друг друга даже в этом у них
система сдержи противо противовес стои
Да здесь разумно это очень выстроено
гармонично и вот Ну конечно как бы
Родина есть Родина для меня Родина
России и понятно что у меня там дышится
как бы здесь я токо привыкаю как бы
погружаюсь но очень когда начинаешь это
чувствовать и понимать Вот лично мне
очень комфортно такой подход Угу угу это
чем-то перекликается с Казахстаном ведь
в Казахстане огромная территория и мало
людей Угу и один Казахстанец Ну казах по
национально очень ум с давно общался сво
время сказал что вот казах когда Что
делает казах Когда видит в степи что
двое дерутся он разворачивается и
скачивает в другую
сторону очень мне это понравилось у
казахов есть много элементов Степной
демократии на самом деле А И вот Степная
демократия Она реально существовала и
там как раз таки
если или Ну богаче или кто
там слишком притесняет то эти люди могли
отковать просто отковать и он остаётся
просто без подопечных Мне очень нравится
идея чтобы кем-то властвовать кого-то
завоёвывать и побо надо всё-таки им
Предлагать что-то такое чтобы им было
хорошо и чтобы они не хотели уходить
очень Разумная
идея Я размышлял над свободой для меня
вобще
свобо такая высшей ценности для меня я
свободу прямо ценю выше всего
материальных благ и так далее Ну я бы
так сказал выше Свободы у меня стоит
только справедливость
а вторая по значимости - это свобода
потому что я прочувствовал и понимаю что
такое жить когда ты чувствуешь что в
отношения тебя поступили несправедливо
это очень
разъедают подавляющее разъедают просто
убивает всё желание даже жить порой так
вот Я размышлял насчёт Свободы думаю Вот
почему американское общество
вроде ну свобода Да это раскрепощает
творчество поэтому появляются новые
технологии и так далее и так далее А я
экстраполировать
что не всё что хорошо для
индивидуума является хорошо для общества
не всё что хорошо для общества то хорошо
для индивидуума Я заметил такую вещь
Свобода тоже такая вещь что а так как я
очень много Обучаю бизнесменов и им
рассказываю про фокус а фокус
целеустремлённость и так далее про
миссию Я им всегда говорю ребята Если вы
хотите пойти дальше то ограничьте свою
свободу потому что
а достижение успеха и Свобода - это два
противоречащих понятия Потому что когда
у тебя есть Свобода движения на
360° то заканчивается тем что ты топчешь
вокруг одного места для того чтобы
добиться успеха нужно продвинуться
дальше а для этого нужно отсечь всё всё
лишнее отсечь то есть ограничивать себя
Вот посмотрите все великие спортсмены
Они же кучу вечеринок пропустили кучу
бань пропустили кучу там концертов
пропустили Почему Потому что они отда
Ну да но да Ну тут весь вопрос очень
важно определить что мы понимаем под
свободой Она для всех важна и для меня
тоже это одна из высших ценностей Но вот
что мы понимаем под свободой потому что
действительно и спортсмены И вообще все
люди которые что-то добиваются Да вообще
которые просто правильно живут и ценны
для других людей они очень много зависит
там от дисциплины они от очень многого
отказываются
даре вот думаю что когда челове
это не означает не Свобода Мне кажется
весь вопрос в том когда его кто-то
заставляет что-то отрезать и что-то
убирать и чем-то не заниматься это
противоречит свободе если я сам решаю
что Да я вот вместо следующие 2 года
вместо дискотек по вечерам Буду рано
ложиться спать там там с утра вставать с
ра светом и писать книгу или там
заниматься спортом или дрессировать
собаку то я думаю это не противоречит
свобода и разгильдяйство - это совсем не
одно и то же же э Владимирович Ленин
умнейший Чувак мы знаем его Да он в своё
время дал чёткое определение Свободы
Свобода - это осознанная необходимость
было такое Да я помню Да это вот я здесь
могу ошибиться или Карл Маркс сказал вот
а один из этих двух умных чуваков а
Свобода - это осознанная необходимость А
я на самом деле
э по-своему определяю свободу на самом
деле свобода определяется горизонтом
планирования человека а если у тебя
дальние горизонты то ты отказываешься от
многих хочу сегодня для достижения
большего в будущем А вот я к тому что
вот относительно общества и относительно
человека вот интересно такой момент в
рамках жизни одного человека если вы
хотите достичь успеха тогда вам нужно
ограничить свою ограничить свою свободу
и сконцентрироваться на чём-то но в
рамках общества
вам нужно максимально давать свободу
максимальную свободу и не ограничивать
людей ни в чём вот то что касательно
бизнеса вот есть разные точки
зрения я больше сторонник того что
бизнес - это всё-таки мышление
собственника Хотя я признаю значение
всех
остальных очень много
тренеров в сети там в и так далее
которые утверждают что бизнес это больше
про инструменты и они тоже по-своему
правы А много людей которые говорят что
бизнес - это больше про людей А вы в том
числе что бизнес это больше про про
людей и вот Давайте поговорим вот над
этой троицей мышление люди инструменты
Вот кто хочет открывать бизнес в Америке
Я немножко изучал эту тему и вот это
связано очень сильно с доверием что Ну
понятно что всегда нужен
пиарю что-то пиарить можно
Кто и пиарить можно что вот что - это
продукт хороший
продукт стригу кого-то или я повар блюдо
это что А кто это я или моя компания и
вот в пиаре всегда есть вопрос Ну один
из вопросов который есть в пире это что
в начале
надоть или
корпоративную культуру изучали эту тему
и вот мы к чему
пришли что в нашем с вами русскоязычном
бизнес пространстве успешные
предприниматели в основном всегда
начинают с кто
[музыка]
Угу я мой моя компания Мой офис и
соответственно Как клиент когда я вхожу
в компанию я всегда интересуюсь кто там
главный Кто там хозяин Кто там директор
и так
далее и там вот у нас если форме взять
кого чень п требует генерального
директора совсем крупный пока мне руку
не помёт владельцу не пойдёт нам на
тренинг или не купит обучение для свого
или там систему тестирования Почему
Потому что на самом деле Доверие низкое
и пожимая мне руку он как бы чуть-чуть
пытается мини
при выть себ себя и свою Компани они не
скромны пото что так правильно но они
заработали там денег приезжают сюда
открывать бизнес И они начинают делать
здесь тоже самое открывают красивый
офис соцсети бренд американцы на него
смотрят
что здесь наоборот
здесь уве
директор и Кто там хозяин и какой у него
офис есть на Манхеттене или там в
силиконовой долине или или где-то ещё
продукт Покажи мне если он качественный
Ну продемонстрирует что кому-то нравится
Они покупают то есть что интересно
получается из-за этого у большинства
русскоязычных предпринимателей здесь
неудача то чтобы прийти сюда открывать
Бизнес надо там быть успешным А если они
успешны Там они привыкли в начале кто
пихать они приходят сюда и пихают Здесь
тоже
самое смотрит здесь никому не интересно
и наоборот поэтому надо просто я советую
тем кто у кого качественный продукт Но
кто какая-то услуга или продукт
качественно кто умеет что-то делать
качественное Но кто в русскоязычном там
звёзд неба не хватает бизнес-сообщества
наоборот им легче здесь начинать потому
что здесь и не требуется этого всего
Пиара и офисов и визиток и и красивую
машину и водителя и вот это вот всё что
мы часы там и вот всё что мы пытаемся
показать здесь это всё не нужно в
меньшей степени по крайней мере это
связано с доверием здесь боль Да вообще
тема доверия большая Я тоже её хотел бы
затронуть немного
вообще доверие вот уровень развития
любой страны можно определить по степени
доверия между членами общества вот даже
приезжая в любую страну я сразу обращаю
внимание например по количеству заборов
вокруг домов и вокруг общественных
зданий я могу суть обро
доверия То есть если на на окнах решётки
Если дома огорожены двух-трёх ветровым
забором значит в этом обществе низкий
уровень доверия между членами общества
раз а низкий уровень согласия значит
очень высоки транзакционные издержки
значит очень много юристов нотариусов
полиции аудиторов и так далее То есть
целые слои людей которые не не
производят продукта а занимаются
обеспечением доверия между людьми Вот
это транзакционный издержки экономики
плюс это очень сильно замедляют
экономику Поэтому в целом доверие и
уровень развития общества или экономики
они очень Прямо коррелирующее понятия
тоже самое когда мы смотрим на компанию
в своё время Изучая корпоративную
культуру мы там нашли 12 драйверов
корпоративной культуры что вот самое
главное для корпоративной Куль Доверие -
это один из из них и один из самых
главных это фундамент на котором всё
остальное Росто если мы посмотрим СМИ
такой простой вопрос зна проц компания
не знаю производит там кухн и устали
Продавец продаёт кухню вот понятно что
там есть специалисты по продажам там все
эти технологии продаж маркетинга там Но
если от всего этого отвлечься и задать
один вопрос кому должен доверять Этот
продавец чтобы успешно продать кухню и
мы увидим что в некотором смысле он
должен обязательно доверять
клиенту клиент в некотором степени
должен доверять самому продавцу дальше
клиент должен доверять в некотором
степени всей компании Дальше они оба
должны доверять государству на самом
деле в некотором смысле а главное Ещё
сам продавец должен доверять своим
производственников своим бухгалтерам
которые представляете сколько должно
быть линий доверия Да чтобы один
продавец продал одну кухню то есть по
сути на самом деле вот эти линии доверия
я это в своё время сравнивал с
кровеносной системой если с телом
связывать вот эти линии доверия это чем
больше доверия тем больше жизни и тем
больше этот организм может что-то
произвести да и
да сказать я смотрите я по поводу
доверия А дело в том что Доверие - это
такая же валюта как любые деньги вот
смотрите Я когда размышлял по поводу
доверия да
А вот в начале же мы торгуем именно
доверием и когда клиент сначала нам даёт
деньги так вот Я заметил такую вещь что
в начале вот сейчас у нас фиатные деньги
до этого были золото до этого были а там
ракушки стекляшки и так далее и так
далее А вот когда вообще этих денег не
было Какая была валюта вот некоторые
говорят бартер бартер бартер когда Да
бартер - это когда у вас есть товар у
меня товар есть а когда нету товара
только Доверие я охотник Я говорю Володя
вот я Оле Да вот
я ам потом осенью отдавал зерно конечно
было больше доверия и торговали доверием
конечно ва и глядя на доверие на уровень
доверия в общество можно сказать что
наше общество в общем и целом
деградирует пото что Доверие становится
меньше пото что 150 лет назад когда вы
были охотником А я сеял пшеницу Ну или
наоборот как вам приятнее мы друг другу
доверяли без подписей без нотариальных
заверений без без гарантий банка и без
всего вот этого дада да а теперь вроде
все эти базы данные интернет и всё вроде
так было бы легко выявлять аферистов и
Ставить их к позорному столбу но мы
меньше доверяем это кстати показывает
духовную деградацию с моей точки зрения
Да я когда размышлял насчёт доверия мы
плотно эту тему изучали и я лично мы Я
даже своё определение Вы наверное знаете
уже Я люблю определение словам давать Я
дал своё определение слову Доверие Угу
сейчас его прочту Оно такое любопытное
может мы можем е поговорить по поводу
него потому что оно и в бизнесе очень
помогает
кому-то У меня тоже есть своё
определение доверия да Давайте сравним
определение слова Доверие это это супер
Сейчас одну
секундочку
Доверие это уверенность в том что тот
кому вы доверяете сделает то что вы от
него ожидаете Когда вы от него это
ожидаете и не сделает того чего вы от
него не ожидаете Когда вы от него этого
не ожидаете
ние дано С математической точность я не
стремился к красоте стремился к
математической точности то есть потому
что в разных ситуациях например от своей
жены хочу я чтобы она со мной спорила
или нет зависит смотря в какой момент
когда мы свом что-то обсуждаем Я очень
хочу чтобы моя жена со мной спорила мне
безмолвные овечки не очень как бы ну мне
нужен
чек Но если я уже Мы приняли решение я
его на семейном совете ОЮ то в этот
момент яве не оче ожидаю что моя же
будет спорить то же самое как от
топ-менеджера сказать
да так вот интересно что в этом
определении Доверие пришлось слово
ожидание упомянуть четыре раза Угу то
есть что отсюда следует что Доверие с
одной стороны Доверие - это фундаменты и
общества и компании корпоративной
культуры но и наших с вами отношений
кстати Доверие фундамент но если мы
посмотрим на на само Доверие то
фундаментом доверия являются ожидания
Вот это проя что мы друг от друга
ожидаем я сейчас поясню Да да я больше
думал предсказуемость Ну я сеча Ну да
тут можно с разных сторон смотреть Но
вот я хотел сказать что вот я недавно в
одной крупной компании мы там поднимали
там вовлечённость там трёхдневный
тренинг делали там в России крупнейший
Строитель дорог в России автомобильных
дорог они наши клиенты там 20 лет
компания Автобан называется Так вот там
был вопрос У них была проблема что там
нарушаются сроки поставки там
контрагенты нарушают сроки сдачи
объектов А у них там своих только там
больше 6 юридических
лиц и вот они вот Доверие же падает
когда кто-то нарушает я говорю да Ну
давайте посмотрим дальше Потому что
обычно когда кто-то нарушает срок
говорим ай-ай-ай ты нарушил Там срок и
ты убиваешь Доверие но в большинстве
случаев эти претензии разбирательства ни
к чему не приводят А если мы посмотрим
на моё это определение и помм что
Доверие - это лишь уверенность в том и
оправдаются ли ожидания или не
оправдаются это весь Вопрос вот да он
сейчас нарушил этот срок там и сделал
эту дорогу там не за 3 месяца А за
четыре О'кей А вот когда мы
договаривались на 3 месяца Это было
обоснованная договорённость или это
просто какой-то острый угол обошёл и
подмахивает
есть люди которые очень мягко стелят
потом жёстко спать это вот то из той же
оперы всё поговорки народная мудрость о
том же говорит а есть люди которые долго
стелят за то как По стелят потом всю
жизнь наслаждаешься да это же именно
здесь формирование за очень часто есть
люди которые формируют завышенное
ожидание Угу И часто это продавцы в
компаниях делает чтобы Клиент купил он
даёт какое-то повышенное обещание дадада
потом что-то не получается и всё
ай-ай-ай Мы там нарушили сроки Доверие
падает Да но до этого Угу под этим мы
позволили сформироваться завышенным
ожиданиям Угу Это Кстати мы с Вами
Сегодня обсуждали е супружеские
отношения я вам говорю что я нашёл 12
врагов Угу супружеского счастья Да 12
убийц вот один из убийц супружеского
счастья - Это завышенное ожидание когда
молодой человек с женщиной
сходится во-первых она там с детства
мечтала о принце и вот она его увидела и
она считает что это принц А потом это
разрушается и он не принц А ещё так
культура общества устроена Что когда мы
знакомимся и вот это вот
конфетно-букетный период Ну кто его как
называет он по сути можно назвать этот
период формирования завышенных ожиданий
друг от друга Ну мужчина расправляет
грудь втягивает живот она прямо выглядит
как цветочек
Там окей а потом мы через 2 года на них
смотрим и там совсем всё по-другому как
бы да Так что вот очень полезно если мы
практически Подходим к доверию и
пытаемся найти причины почему оно
подрывается очень часто
помогает отойти на два шага назад как
всегда и посмотреть а не были ли
сформированы завышенные ожидания
угу вот да в в отношении доверия я
а вот тоже много размышлял и понимаю что
основной продукт доверия - это
предсказуемость потому что ценность
доверия в том что она формирует среду
предсказуемости ты ведь в конечном итоге
мы все же люди мы не любим не
определённость абсолютно мы не любим
неопределённость и нам нужно всё
структурировать чтобы было всё
определённо но в некотором смысле Когда
вы говорите слово предсказуемость это
очень близко к тому что говорю я потому
что предсказуемость в некотором смысле
это я это ожидаю и это получаю да да Это
же просто мы говорим об одном и том же
только с разных сторон по сути да с
разных сторон И я вот например определяю
Доверие от слова до достойно Веры
доверия достойно веры и вот как
вопрос возникновения доверия откуда
вообще Доверие возникает
интересно Это я нашл у древних
греков древние греки ещё определили Три
источника доверия
это Пафос и логос Три источника доверия
это это
действие То есть если я что-то говорю а
потом Подтверждаю действиями то у вас
автоматически возникает ко мне доверие
если я логически ВС
обосновывать то у вас автоматически
возникает ко мне доверие и третье это
Пафос если я рассказываю про какое-то
событие в своей жизни и рассказываю про
те чувства которые я испытывал в то
время если вы переживали такое же то вы
можете определить Действительно ли я
попадал в такие ситуации или нет через
те чувст
он там бы потому что я тоже так
чувствовал себя в такой ситуации и вот
Три источника возникновения доверия это
логос и Пафос вообще тема доверия она
обширнее это основа основа и фундамент
для любого человеческого
взаимодействия это основа и фундамент
для эффективности Я очень много
занимаюсь эффективностью и для меня это
просто важнейшая веь потому что вообще в
истории чело было два скачка
эффективности первый скачок
эффективности когда люди начали работать
объединёнными усилиями то есть
коллективный труд на само на самом деле
коллективный труд позволил нам
Выжить и второе - это разделение труда
но разделение труда - это менее с точки
зрения воздействия на человечество менее
важно важнее было именно первый
коллективный Т бев Для этого необходимо
Доверие было для это необходимо было
Доверие это и это основа вообще и у
нас Поэтому если человек ведёт себя
непредсказуемого непредсказуемого таких
людей говорят он неадекватный и начинают
его изолировать потому что ему
невозможно доверять мы начинаем его
изолировать и раньше такие люди умирали
Ну а в сегодняшнем мире понятно не
умирают но они живут изгоями но в
целом Доверие - это вот именно тот клей
та основа
на основе которого строятся любые наши
взаимодействия тут мы с вами абсолютно
солидарны можно переходить к людям в
бизнесе да да вот теперь касательно
вопросов бизнеса А как я сказал это
Триада - это сам собственник второе это
вот именно его мышление второе - это
люди и третье инструменты да А давайте
давайте поговорим о вот этой триаде Что
важнее что первично что вторично и так
далее и так далее Как вы думаете
Я думаю что во всех Вот таких Триада
подобных А их несколько есть в разных
областях жизни конечно необходимы все
три
составляющие в некотором смысле е
сказать что там бизнес можно делать без
инструментов Ну это понятно не
очень без людей но что это за бизнес без
собственника без его мышления Так что
конечно нужны все три элемент Но если
пытаться говорить Какой главный или
какой более
актуальный думае зависит от подхода от
индивидуальности человека Каждому своё
ли говорит лично обо мне исходя из моего
опыта из моей
экспертизы Я наверно сторонник если вот
надо выделить главный определяющий
причинный Да я бы наверное говорил бы о
двух это о мышлении собственника и о
людях Я бы инструменты откладывал бы
чуть-чуть
второстепенному что без них можно
Конечно они нужны Но они всё-таки скорее
являются следствием
Угу мышление первого лица его картины
мира его убеждения его принципов его
ценности Там и так далее и тех людей
которые ему удалось взять в
компании например могу сказать что вот
Изучая Ту же самую корпоративную
культуру там лет 10 назад мы я попалось
мне одно исследование Если не ошибаюсь
манзи Ну может быть нет ну кого-то
каких-то из миллиард вот ребят из
консалте миллиард и они провели
исследование и выяснили равная культура
компании минимум на
40% зависит просто в лоб от личности
первого
лица то
есть от его мышления естественно Ну
а а люди это как бы понятно что с него
всё начинается и в некотором смысле его
мышление это основа всего это первый
источник конечно но что происходит
Дальше это превратилось в бизнес а не
было театром одного
АК Люди у него
будут поэтому я вот бы вот если бы мне
задача ставила бы из этих трх выбрать бы
два на которых остановиться Я бы говорил
о мышлении и о
людях ещё кстати говоря знаете один из
исполнительных директоров
ама я вспомнил сказал очень Забыл его
фамилию он был очень интересный товарищ
но сказал такую фразу что единственное
что нас не могут украсть наши конкуренты
- это нашу корпоративную культуру
а корпоративна культура это люди То есть
все вот эти инструменты ноу-хау
технологии ВС Вот это это ВС можно
украсть и крадут но при этом это не
работает в той компании почему пото что
там люди другие да то есть значит
вс-таки люди являются более перво
причиной по отношению к инструмента вот
я я бы как бы склонен к такому подходу а
мышление
собствени работаете Я думаю что это ну
одна из самых одна из самых или самая
важная точка
приложения от этого дальше Всё
раскручивается я бы я бы так сказал что
Понятно инструменты в последнюю очередь
потому что инструменты могут команд
использовать эти инструменты
собственнику даже не
всегда нужно знать эти инструменты и так
далее не Все нужно знать Конечно вот
здесь я бы сказал так вообще задача
собственника на самом деле это
собственник - это детонатор
детонатор или вот знаете в автомобиле
есть большой двигатель который двигает
машину А есть стартер который заводит
двигатель Угу Так вот собственник - это
стартер который заводит двигатель а
двигатель - Это команда которая двигает
машину абсолютно ясно да и и здесь
вопрос такой нету стартера не Заведётся
двигатель но в то же время на стартере
далеко не уедешь стартер он Маши курица
или яйцо как бы стартер он машину тянуть
не может да И вот здесь Я заметил такую
вещь что с одной стороны я не
переоценивают собственника а потому что
я знаю много корпораций которые вот
например Стив Джобс он запустил Apple Но
дальше команда дальше команда
корпоративно управление оно начинает уже
она новые продукты создавать и так далее
и так далее То есть то же самое что в
двигателе после того как ты завёл
стартер может уже отдыхать Ну то есть не
продолжать крутить молотить двигатель
работает абсолютно но всё-таки от
примера двигателя и стартера чем это
отличается что там есть стартер есть
двигатель а в бизнесе команда - это вещь
динамическая приобретаемая и создаваемая
и тоже Стив Джобс если почитать его
биографию провёл Лично от 2 до 3000
интервью по найму на
работу Он создал этот двигатель А Он
проводил интервью не по полчаса ради То
есть он встречался с людьми с которыми
он летел или к нему прилетали там как
минимум у не Ну в данном случае когда я
говорю стартер имеется в виду он не
запускает готовую команду он сначала её
создаёт Вот вот я говорю про создание
Просто он е создаёт потом запускает я бы
сказал что там есть мышление
собственника где-то совсем в начале но
следующим шагом идёт то как собственник
привлекает людей и вот есть одно из
умений которое я считаю какие-то
инструменты и умения не нужны первому
лицу Но вот умение выбрать нужных людей
нуж от ненужных вот непонятно чем это
заменить конечно этим можно заниматься
кто-то скажет но я прошу прощения и
самого нужно выбрать как у сотен наших
клиентов там если слабый H то и всё А
кто этого H выбрал генеральный директор
хорошо а генерального директора кто
выбрал ОПС всё равно собственник Ну как
бы так что всё равно тут вопрос вот этот
вот как первое Лицо со своим мышлением
может подобрать тех кому можно доверять
и кто привнес нужный вклад
ещ провожу аналогию со стартером Почему
Потому что собственнику важно Запусти
построить двигатель запустить и вовремя
отойти а потому что в огромных
количествах
случаев мышление собственника она уже
чем мышление коллектива группы людей
соответственно если правильно построен
двигатель он лучше может работать без
собственника и здесь вопрос вот о ЧМ что
л такую веь что вообще любая команда в
любом бизнесе - это по сути
система и свойство Одной из главных
свойств системы Это называется
эмерджентные свойство То есть то что
появляется синергия это то что не
присущее ни одному из членов этой
системы но присущие всей системе в целом
И
вот именно создавать команду нужно ВС
искусство заключается не в том чтобы
собрать звёзды когда ты собираешь звёзд
получается бардак это сборище эгоистов
Да абсолютно синергию дости потому что
они не дают вот этот Искры не возникает
Ну это самое сложное в найме могу вам
сказать вот самое сложное в создании
команды именно создать звёздную команду
а не команду звёзд конечно Абсолютно
Звёздная команда са слож И вот я считаю
вот основная задача собственника именно
и мышление ему нужно только для этого и
может быть для этого нуж какие-то
инструменты и тогда эти инструменты
нужны собственнику А ну Хотя многие это
делают интуитивно это больше про
мышление
мен Я согласен да Безусловно безусловно
но так или иначе это такое Да это прямо
основополагающие вещи я заметил такую
вещь очень многие люди бизнесмены
создают команды то есть формально они
идут всё правильно правильный Co
правильный HR правильный там
коммерческий директор правильный
маркетолог ро но команды Нет ну когда вы
говорите правильно правильно это
выглядит на стене красиво на схеме А
насколько это правильно это определяется
насколько они усиливают друг друга
насколько есть Синергия и в большинстве
компаний её нету Вы правы И значит это
неправильно ну здесь вопрос в том что
условно говоря есть определённые
показатели людей там эффективности Да
они эффективны они квалифицированные они
всё нормально но когда их собираешь
вместе они не дают дополнительную
ценность
Вот я считаю основная прибыльность
возникает не от работы профессионалов а
от работы команды профессионалов которые
дают обычно если у каждого условно пять
членов команды каждый даёт по два это 10
но когда команда работает они дают и 20
и 30 конечно конечно Ну вот если
говорить о людях более так сказать
предметно и Ну вы сейчас проходите наш
тренинг Вы там не закончили да Половину
Да но
вот вот за вот эту вот организацию
синергии что
отвечает же мы и наши клиенты уже
тестировали 3 млн кандидатов из которых
80.000 успешно принято на работу то есть
как бы такая экспертиза
очень большая у нас и могу вам сказать
что вот понятно что есть продуктивность
и знание два фактора на которые мы
смотрим и все остальные часто
определяющие Но вот на что мало кто
смотрит на что смореть
по что непонятно как Ну люди пытаются
это интуитивно у нас там и интуиция и
инструменты есть ещё это
вовлекаемых подходом про
вовлекает слева потому что все думают
как вовлечь сотрудника но мало кто
понимает что это ещё от сотрудника
зависит потому что мы сотрудников то
одинаково
увлекаемся а кто-то нет значит это ещё
от самих сотрудников зави понятно что
надо нанимать тех кто более вовлекает Ну
а четвёртое личностные качества и вот
гармония в личностных качеств и
вовлекаемых
совсем такая почти неуловимая Вещь Вот
это и отвечает за то что получалась
Синергия Или наоборот не получалась Это
команда единоличных звёзд которые только
лбами стучатся и искры идут вы знаете Я
изучал в своё
время крупнейшие исследования Google
проводил в двенадцатом году они
потратили миллионы долларов
они изучали все успешные команды они
проверили 699 команд Угу а странная
цифра 6 Почему не 700 непонятно Ну 699
команд А причём они изучали вплоть до
того кто с кем предпочитает обедать а
ужинать а говорить кто у кого Где
находится стол у окна или в коридоре и
так далее Кто в какой команде работает
возраст пол вообще вдоль и поперёк все
команды они проше стили и там были и
инженерные команды и творческие команды
и так далее и так далее И этот проект
грандиозный проект он назвался проект
Аристотель они его так назвали Да
Аристотель проект Аристотель - это
крупнейшая в истории исследования
эффективности команд
и интересно вот я раньше был сторонник
того что А вот и казны технологии я
считал Так что
из плохого сырья вы никогда не сделаете
хороший продукт из хорошего сырья У вас
есть шанс сделать хороший продукт но нет
гарантий я больше раньше
упирался эффективность команды не влияет
не столько состав участников команды
сколько их взаимоотношения между собой
ну то есть чтобы они друго усиливали и
появлялась эта Синергия
нет основное что влияло на эффективность
команды это ощущение
безопасности то есть что люди могут
говорить и они точно знают что их никто
не унизит Никто не будет
критиковать никто все
всем членам команды пон
соучастниками приняти решений правильных
решени хорошая мысль Я с ней согласен но
мне надо посмотреть это исследование
потому что вообще ощущение безопасности
и вот это Безопасность это вот один из
драйверов вовлечённости чтобы люди
чувствовали себя в безопасно но он не
единственный это не единственно Но это
основной фактор который влияет на эктив
го
хотел бы посмотреть на это у меня есть
некоторые То есть это один из основных
вот могу вам при сказать что я по
статистике вот те факторы которые влияют
на вовлечённость не на эффективность А
на вовлечённость мы их там насчитали 12
Ну кто кто как считает Ну вот мы считаю
что их 12 Ну неважно безопасность в
любом случае один из них Но вот например
в русскоязычном бизнес пространстве
знаете какой фактор это называется
драйвер Да что сильно жалеет один из
драйверов вовлечённости самый проса
сжимает всю Вов в русскоязычном
пространстве это карьера и развитие что
люди не видят будущего в Компани не
видят карьеру и не видят развитие То
есть я не знаю какие они 700 компаний
изучали где В какой области В
како Какие Но то что Безопасность это
один из важнейших факторов влияющих на
вовлечённость эффективностью соответству
внутренних команд то с с вопросами
карьеры И карьерного роста у них не
стояло это этой проблемы вообще потому
что в Гугле Понятно Карьерная лестница
Вот я и говорю что я думаю что они
просто изучали среди тех где многие
вопросы решены но когда наши подписчики
слушатели там ваши ученики нас слушают
Не факт что у них это решено как в Гугле
не но я Однако говорю вот о чём я говорю
ребята не стремитесь сразу же бежать на
рынок и искать крутых людей
сча чисто из своего жизненного опыта Я
говорю Я заметил такую ве что команда
она как истребитель Она любит скорость и
она любит нагрузки самое интересное
е если
вы Интересно такую вещь у меня много
было супер крутых команд когда ты не
даёшь команде амбициозной
затра кома грузить по полной программе и
ставить задачи за пределами за пределами
звука сверхзвуковые задачи это первое
поэтому команда любит скорость второе
команда любит нагрузку и здесь я такую
вещь часто говорю Ребята
а для того чтобы резко увеличить
эффективность команды просто резко сразу
Возьмите если у вас команда 10 человек
сразу двоих увольте самых неэффективных
самых негатив двоих Уволь это кстати
исследовани Google сказано там было
сказано Так что
А даже один негатив один негативно
настроенный участник команды убивает
творческий потенциал девяти эффективных
сотрудников Ну есть такие один негатив
продуктивные В распространении негатива
Да ну я я в этом плане говорю поэтому
Когда вы
увольняет Приходите просто говорю просто
первое что не надо искать крутых людей
вот хотите чтобы ваша команда резко
взбодрись и стала более эффективный
приходите если 10 человек берёте двоих
увольняет самых негатив ков и
неэффективных к чему это приводит
во-первых вы резко повышаете
справедливость уровень справедливости
потому что эффективные члены команды
смотрели на этих и думали Блин мы
одинаково получаем Но эти нихена не
работают а эти Когда вы тех увольняет
они такие ну наконец-то блин начальство
разобралась Кто есть кто то есть уровень
справедливости вы во-первых поднимаете
во-вторых вы начинаете грузить
оставшихся Но если они эффективные они
от этого только кайфат и поэтому говорю
Не надо бежать искать крутых людей
сначала увольте негатив ков дальше А
дальше уже это выстроить правильные
взаимоотношения между теми восьми
которые остались это даст ещё второй бу
второй бу и потом толь
може
ВМ согласен очень часто мы не ценим тех
людей которые уже есть Это точно Это
точно Это точно у меня лет 15 назад
главный редактор одного там журнала
бизнесов спросил Какая самая большая
распространённая ошибка
предпринимателей я подумал подумал
сказал терпение и Надежда Угу Ну то есть
терпение непродуктивных сотрудников и
надежда что они начнут работать хорошо
Так что с тем что от них надо если
кто-то там в течение нескольких недель
Или в крайнем случае месяцев не
показывает то что должен показать или
тем более негативен Конечно надо
избавляться легче Да по поводу
справедливости абсолютно правильно это
это кстати очень важное замечание что
вот сбрасывая этот баласт мы Кроме всего
прочего восстанавливаем справедливость
Потому что я в своё время могу сказать
может это будет интересно там слушателям
подписчикам что я в своё время лет
наверное 10
назад осознал вещь от которой у меня
встали волосы дыбом я не мог спать
несколько ночей волосы дыбом - это в
вашем случае хорошо Ну те которые есть
ещё оставшиеся оставшиеся здесь это не
видно ну 10 лет назад с другой стороны
здесь ещ тоже было что-то видно да что я
ворую
деньги я ворую деньги у кого у своих
лучших сотрудников правда и это было
просто я не балуюсь это было я не просто
как бы красивые слова потому что мы
многие предприниматели Ну когда там наши
клиенты я с ними разговаривают там там
типа ну да я Вот его
плохо работает Ну что поделаешь Ну да Ну
я теряю на это деньги я ему отдаю свои
деньги это
неправда ты ему отдаёшь не свои деньги
пото что свои деньги ты ему отдавал Если
бы ты их очистил от налогов выбил бы в
прибыль привёз домой жену там на стол
жене на стол положил сказал вот это там
на это это это это А это куда спросил А
это Я отнесу тем кто плохо работает вот
тогда ты бы давал ему свои деньги но
никто так не делает А у нас есть на
самом деле неважно белая бухгалтери
серая или ЧР есть какой-то зарплатный
фонд или место какое-то
и вот оттуда мы платим все зарплаты то
есть грубо говоря есть там человек или
пять которые наполняют этот фонд А мы
делим его на десятерых То есть это что
значит я у этих ребят без спроса беру их
деньги отдаю тем кто работает плохо то
есть я ворую у них деньги Поэтому Вы
абсолютно правы очень сильный
терапевтический эффект это убрать тех
кто не должен получать день самое
интересное знаете
Откуда мне мыс такая
прила Один мой товари начал заниматься
скотом он уехал в степ начал выращивать
скот
и знаете когда скот болеет там их надо
отделять карантин лечить для этого надо
держать вид врачей за техников и
возвращать строй и так далее И вот был в
Карагандинской области один немец у него
всегда было Передовое хозяйство крутой
там герой сода иле и вот мог его и
Горите оптом
или там 80 С чем-то лет старикашка ему
говорит Поделитесь он а он соскучился по
Казахстану он говорит я приеду и он
приехал в Казахстан к нему
и говорит А вот в чём секрет почему у
вас было самый лучший приветствие самые
лучшие это там экономика и так далее он
говорит у меня методика была очень
простая у меня говорит скот пасётся
чихнул под нож захма под нож А там это
что-то такое
закашлялся заразы и так далее и весь
скот всё время был здоровый с другой
стороны если мы начнём это на команды
распространять то нас могут не понять
эти методы надо как-то вид изменить Я же
говорю про принцип Я же говорю про
принцип в этом плане
подно это увольнять да увольнять
увольнять мы всё-таки гуманисты да да
это увольняет но я к тому
что смотрите нас же в конечном итоге
вообще бизнесменов вознаграждают За что
За эффективность
а эффективны мы можем когда быть когда
мы здоровы Когда мы Пашем когда Мы горим
и так далее
и рынок точно не вознаграждает нас за
содержание дармоедов там слабых и так
далее так далее конечно не хотя общество
правительство всякие журналисты иногда
говорят вот он создал столько рабочих
мест Он создал столько То есть это тоже
какой-то побочная вещь за что общество
вознаграждает Но на самом деле конечно
нас награждают не за количество рабочих
мест конечно коне рабочие места
создавать надо но они должны быть
эффективны они должны быть заняты теми
людьми которые на них что-то производят
безус Ну вот в целом то что касательно
вообще мышление собственника на самом
деле вопросом много занимаюсь не только
даже вообще мышлением собственника
базовый вопросами эффективного мышления
много занимаюсь я считаю моя основная
фишка чем я люблю вообще заниматься и я
заметил такую вещь что не один бизнес не
бывает круче чем эффективность мышления
собственника То есть он всегда является
узким горошком Ява полком
негоже ниже все сотрудники члены команды
всегда он берёт ниже себя и даже если Он
возьмёт крутых людей то он не может
управлять ими потому что его мышление
это не позволяет А и здесь интересный
такой момент а а я заметил такую вещь
что очень часто В чём это выражается
выражается в том что они в людях
предпринимателя Да предпринимателей А в
чём выражается именно узость мышления в
отношении команды в том что они видят в
команде расходы а не доходы Ну да они
относятся к этому как к расходам они
относятся как к расходам относись как к
инвестициям
я сю инвести я больше отношусь даже как
к доходам Ну да здесь Вопрос вот в
чём когда Большинство предпринимателей
смотрят на команду как на расходы они
начинают экономить они начинают
экономить на них они начинают брать
дешёвых людей то есть Ну понятно и не
доплачивать и так далее и так далее
А мне задают вопрос спрашивают А в чём
вот ещё проявляется вот наша узость
мышления Я говорю в том что смотрите вы
это на самом деле ваша проблема а вы
перекладывать вину на них вот если ты
вот почему ты не можешь взять крутого
человека потому что ты на него смотришь
как на расходы А проблема же не в нём а
проблема в том что ты не можешь его
загрузить на всю его мощность Это
примерно как ты с мышлением ты подходишь
мышлением Лада prora и тебе дали
Mercedes но ты не можешь ездить 200 км
ВЧ у тебя не хватает умения ездить 200
км ВЧ Потому что ты всю жизнь ездил на
Лада Приора 60 кмч и ты теперь хочешь
Mercedes иметь по цене Лада Приора Но
это же твоя проблема в том что ты не
можешь из
мерседесам поэтому я говорю фишка
заключается в том что платить выше ранк
я вот предпочитаю платить чуть выше
рынка всегда ты платишь чуть выше рынка
и при этом Этот человек должен знать что
он получает выше рынка но при этом ты
грузишь его на 200-300 500 про и вот а
эффективные люди любят эффективные Люди
любят когда и самый интересный феномен
происходит Я много раз убеждался вот ты
берёшь эффективного человека начинаешь
его грузить и он знаете что происходит
Он резко начинает повышать свою
эффективно
конечно ты е е г успевает ты е грузи он
е успевает ты е Гру он е успевает То
есть он знаете как самозатачивающийся
механизм ты больше его грузишь Он резко
начинает увеличивать свою эффективность
Да ну я мы одинаково с вами на очень
многие вопрос смотрим и конечно хорошо
платить по рынку или даже выше рынка Я
согласен но просто когда вы говорите что
вот я ему плачу больше и загружая он
начинает в разы больше работать это
вс-таки не любой так то есть надо
платить выше рынка загружать но ещё
необходимо к этому приложить то что я
нашл того кого можно загрузить и кто
готов расти и производить всё больше и
больше всё-таки не любой не Это ясно что
не любой я про это гою что вот это ещ
составляю сожалению со всеми подряд
Такое не проходит и можно кстати говоря
вот Многие думают что вот если платить
много то там куча проблем в организации
решится у меня в своё время эксперимент
я проводил я там лет 30 назад мы скупали
магазины в Москве продовольственные
потом что-то с ними делали в основном я
в аренду и сдавал но в некоторых Мы
продолжали рою торговлю был момент когда
я там лично руководил там одной из
крупнейших сетей продовольственных
магазинов в Москве три магазина было
там 250 сотрудников работало Что такое
Короче говоря вот у меня с партнёрами
возник спор Я там одну вещь продвигал
там что делани гово Да мы просто им
недо и эти кода
был такой взрывной 30 лет назад я Сейчас
успокоился Ну хорошо говорю давай хочешь
больше платить Лано На сколько ты хочеш
поднять минимум на 50 лучше в два раза
хорошо
поднимай мы подняли всем зарплату в два
раза Ну просто в штатном писании Дону в
два раза Через 3 месяца ко мне пришёл
говорит Володя ты прав Всё я сдаюсь хуже
стал не лучше а хуже да То есть хорошо
поднимать заплату и платить много если в
ответ ИТ то что это
то есть грубо говоря всё всё равно
должно на балансе вот баланс того что мы
даём и что полу здесь ещё такой очень
интересный лайфхак в своё время и такая
самая распространённая ошибка наверное
многие бизнесмены так говорят вот у него
появился крутой продажник они берут его
ставят руководителем отдела продажи Ну
это колоссальная ошибка это классическая
ошибка причём
результа плохой руководитель отдела
продаж и он потерял Е
и получает хорошего начальника дела
наоборот теряет хорошего продавца и
получает плохого начальника дела самое
главное отыграть это назад нельзя я вот
могу сказать Этот человек уволится У
меня есть Кстати ноу-хау как можно
попробовать отыграть А я я я сейчас
расскажу как я делаю давайте давайте
обменяемся я смотрите что делаю я беру
вот работают люди Я начинаю грузить их
больше их функциональных обязанностей Я
начинаю грузить грузить грузить грузить
потом в какой-то момент кто-то приходит
говорит Аче вы это даже мои обязанности
не входит что Вы с меня требуете такой А
да Ой извини я начинаю ему назад
откатывать его а сам ставлю галочку не
хочет
расти и я начинаю грузить грузить
грузить кто-то в какой-то момент уже по
факту выполняет обязанности начальника
отдела И после этого я должность как
пальто ему одеваю и говорю приводите в
соответствие просто должность ты ты
начальник одела Он говорит Да не я ещё
не исправлюсь ты уже Ты уже делаешь Это
всё и тогда я не теряю специалиста но
приобретаю хорошего начальника дела Ну
да кстати говоря вот желание человека
выйти за рамки своих обязанностей это
прямо по определению одна из необходимых
составляющих вовлечённости Угу желание
выйти за рамки своих обязанности то есть
по сути вы таким образом нащупывается
вовлечённых сотрудников это вот не не не
я вот не то что провожу опрос Кто хочет
не хочет да на практике Я понимаю я
понимаю Дада лучше это проверка боем
называется проверка
Просто иногда проблема в том что иногда
грузить мы иногда грузим просто больше
даём но не факт что мы даём все
обязанности начальника и всё равно когда
мы его делаем начальником есть небольшой
риск что у него может не получиться Это
уже зависит от наших там там вопрос Там
вопрос только вот в чём он может
выполнять функциональные обязанности
начальника но он может не брать риск да
Ну я про это и гово нуно например
вот это единствен И вот когда У меня
есть ноу-хау Как сделать чтобы откатить
это как бы когда вот у меня спрашивают А
как вот я вот он хороший продавец но я
боюсь его сделать там роком нуно вроде
он Я его гружу он там вовлечённых готов
Ну вот я всё-таки сомневаюсь то Ну
понятно что это зависит от обученности
там от компетенции там в принципе можно
проверить человека и с большой
уверенностью сказать получше ли его быть
начальником Но если такой возможности
нет и надо быстро что-то посоветовать то
на житейском на бытовом уровне работает
вот что что когда я вот с ним
предприниматель там первое лицо
руководитель проводит беседу и говорит о
переводе с продавца на на
ропа Договориться с ним что это
эксперимент чтоб с одной стороны конечно
чтобы Что бывает если мы взяли хорошего
продавца там лучше сделали его Ром у
него не получается Он уже закусился он
сопротивляется там ну начинаются
конфликты и всё у него неудача всё
он попробовать это вго контекст поме
надежд или есть основание полагать что у
тебя получится у тебя есть желание у
тебя есть задатки у тебя есть потенциал
Давай вместе попробуем но как
эксперимент но прямо сейчас договоримся
там мы три там 3 месяца пробуем через
Каждый месяц мы будем разговаривать с
тобой и подводить итоги как Но если мы
решим что не получится вместе решим то
мы не будем рассматривать это как
катастрофу а просто отойдём на исходную
В некоторых случаях это смягчает как бы
вот эту ситуацию и помогает поть как бы
пробный период сделать
изначально контекст создать чтобы
человек не закусывай к этому относился
но не всегда бывает Неда не всегда но В
некоторых случаях это может Вот я просто
из опыта то что у меня из опыта лучше
получается это когда грузишь грузишь
грузишь А потом когда он уже реально
выполняет
обязанности тогда делаешь начальником
знаете Вы сейчас сказали Я вспоминаю и
свои компании и клиентов куда явлен
Наверно это
дест надёжный
способ Может правда е подучить надо для
этого чето интересно он бесконфликтный
ты грузишь грузишь если человек
проявляет
недовольство наза отка сам галочку
ставишь он не хочет расти всё Ну вот это
реально очень сильно работает Да
особенно если ещё вам люди доверяют и
понимаешь Если вы грузите то в конце
концов они за это что-то получат тут
опять в основе должно быть доверие и
понимание что вы разум человек а вы
знаете а есть категория людей э которым
всё равно грузится согла но не всем Кому
всё равно кому не всё равно они по раз
да вот а вот самое интересное что
хорошие руководители обычно те которые
Просто грузятся и делают делают делают
Дела Дела А есть ещё вообще крутые люди
которые даже не преследуют э там сразу
же каких-то своих корыстных интересов им
нравится вызовы им нравится
на этом все компании держатся горке
таких людей Им нравятся вызовы они прямо
рую чем больше сложность тем они Да
врубаю то что на самом чем больше чем
сложнее задача тем больше удовольствия и
удовлетворения её решения они это зна
это кстати знают только продуктивные
люди вот этот кайф когда это мы
используем в привлечении кандидатов могу
одну тайну открыть для
подписчиков что как вот привлечь
продуктивного кандидата потому что
многие в объявлении расписывают отпуск
летнее время и высокая зарплата и
обучение это это и соцпакет ну кто идт
на эти объявления вы
понимаете мы иногда советуем делать
объявление там наоборот пугать
людей жуткая сложная работа выдержит
один там из 100000 Ну вот идея такая
Зачем вы такое объявление все же
пугаются Да все пугаются нам все и не
нужны Но тот кто продуктив Хой товари
кто знает рения
Он на эту приманку и
клют Но это Но это известно только
продуктивным людям кто в прошлом в своей
жизни сами испытали кайф от решения
сложных задач Вот именно таких людей
такими объявлениями ня у меня один из
моих менеджеров он уволился потом
ушёл в другой компании работал и так
далее и так далее и через какое-то время
мне опять
Т есть прое пожне пожёстче чтобы там
А был кризис Зачем
хочу Да ну у меня такого нет проек но он
говорит именно пожёстче поне приятно
когда просится обратно Это здорово Да
посложнее и пожёстче есть что-нибудь
посложнее и пожёстче то есть вот он
такой кризис менеджер и прямо знаете
этот костр или убийца расходов и ещё
может быть ему там куда он ушёл может
быть он там Заскучал по что
ну честно говоря я от меня он ушёл
потому что заскучал то Ну может от
вас порешал вопросы одну компанию Да
стало скучно он ушёл а потом там ему
стало скучно он опять у меня попросил
это но у
меняющий раз мне говорите у нас для
таких есть всегда работа клиенты всегда
таких
ищут вобще вот интересно что вот есть
категория лю
как раз таки категория людей Ну
кризисные менеджеры траблшутеры да с
другой стороны
конечно такие люди Они хороши и с точки
зрения отдачи видно от них всё и они
классные но я заметил такую ещё вещь
а для искусство бизнеса же не в том
чтобы всё время газовать да всё время
захватывать есть захватчики есть те
которые пото
земледельцы которые рутина каждый день
всё время делают и так далее и так далее
ну нужно комбинация тех и тех Да и
причём не просто комбинация А в
зависимости от динамического состояния
бизнеса конечно конечно а у бизнеса
разные этапы есть есть этапы экспансии
есть этапы стабилизации экспансия
стабилизация экспансия стабилизация по
сути как та как дыхание Ну это если вы
говорите о директоре о ключевых людях но
в принципе у каждой компании есть
функции захватнические и удерживающие
даже если посмотреть на должности Пони
да да да но вот главно Если говорить о
главном человеке Это зависит от этапа
компании безусловно Да от этапа компании
очень много потому что прямо есть ярко
выраженные периоды экспансии потом
периоды даже чуть-чуть откат немного и
стабилизации
и я ещё знаете в най заметил такую вещь
что парадоксально вообще на мне тоже
очень интересен в плане вообще общение с
людьми не только найм Да потому что найм
это есть общение с людми парадокса вещь
такую заметил когда я анализировал
вообще я очень сильно склонен к
рефлексии очень много рефлексировать по
поводу своих ошибок прошлого успехов и
так далее и так далее Я заметил такую
вещь что я всё время ошибался тогда
когда мне нравились
кандидаты и вот Я когда начал
анализировать я понял такую вещь
что оказывается я на работу брал
тех людей которые мне нравились а
нравились они мне потому что они были
такие же как я или похожи на вас да и
получа себе подобного и что я понял
такую вещь а потом когда я начал
анализировать своих лучших менеджеров я
понял такую
вещь абсолютно конт интуитивно и С тех
пор я у меня такой чек-лист если человек
кандидат Мне
нравится восклицательный
ставлю восклицательный зна
а если кандидат Мне не нравится Я тоже
ставлю восклицательный знак в плане того
что я заметил такую вещь что все мои
крутые менеджеры при первой встрече
всегда не нравились мне я понял причину
они другие они не могут себя продавать
Угу они могут делать рутинной рутину они
могут пахат как лошадки но они не умеют
себя продавать они скромные Да ну вот
это вот они любят больше делом
доказывать нежели словами Ну вот это вот
то что вы вот ту область которую вы
сейчас зашли это показывается нашим
личностным тестом там это не так
однозначно но в принципе абсолютно вот
то что Говорите То что вот многие
предприниматели на на те же грабли что и
Вы наступают они нанимают тех кто им
нравится а нравятся им такие как они
если это лихой захватчик который любит
новое любит отлично он таких и берёт но
нельзя всё время захватывать кто-то
потом должен там ежедневно
каш чистить зна она мыть Нарезать огур и
линто обживать абсолютно и Но вот для
этого поэтому-то инструменту вот в таких
случаях помните мы говорили вот в этом
случае Нам нужен инструмент потому что
понимаете Когда вам кто-то не
нравится Мне он не нравится но вам может
быть не
нра в большинстве случаев вам супер
продуктивному человеку не нравится
кандидат Когда вы просто интуитивно
чувствуете что он непродуктивный что он
лжец Ну то есть даёт ложную информацию
что он просто пиарит себя и без мыла
пытается залезть к вам в компанию на
самом деле цена г те те сразу понятно да
да но но и они вам тоже не нравятся
Поэтому иногда нам не нравится но и по
разным причинам так же как и нравится
пото что иногда вам нравится человек
потому что он такой же как и тогда надо
тельный знак поставить но иногда вам
нравится то что вы нюхом чувствуете
супер
продуктивного Понимаете вот вот чтобы
различать это вот вот у нас пришла и
третья вершина нашего треугольника
какие-то инструменты всё равно могут
помочь а здесь
интересно когда у
человека что-то хромает он начинает
компенсировать другими вещами Да Нуне и
я для себя такую ве поня
и я начал придумывать
разные инструменты
как минимизировать свои ошибки интересно
открыл такие способы у меня несколько
есть способов один из способов я скажу
так например
я ищу финансиста предположим если я ищу
финансиста то что я
делаю профессиональный тест Понятно
прое проверить я сам это могуть знани
финансов А есть личностные качества
которые мне нужно проверить Например я
очень ценю людей скромных Я люблю ценю
людей честных порядочных скромных и так
далее как мне самому выявить Дело в том
что так как я сам по себе не скромен то
я не могу меня можно обмануть я что
делаю я в своих компаниях Благо у меня
много компаниях мысленно
представляю лове как с теми личностными
качествами которые я ищу скромный
порядочный честный и его прошу провести
собеседование и интересно что Рыбак
рыбака видит издалека А вот его обмануть
уже никак не получится Вот это ни разу
меня не подводил вот этот инструмент Вот
например мне нужно скромного честного
порядочного я так у меня в той компании
такой-то человек Блин мне нравится он он
никогда не обманывал меня чем порядочным
скромен и так далее я его приглашаю
говорю вот у меня есть кандидат проведи
собеседование Скажи мне он такой такой
такой и не такой и этот человек идёт ни
разу ошибок не было ни разу ошибок не
удивительно работает вот это рыбака это
я как вот например если кто-то придёт
мне и начнёт говорить что он охотник или
там гольфист Я через два слова раку его
конечно но это это уже Мы говорим о
проверке знаний вот по нашей технологии
проверке зна Самое главное чтобы тот кто
проверял у него у него самого они были
да тогда он пря но вы сейчас Знаете
сказали насчёт своего хитрого способа Я
вспомнил такой полу смешной способ у
меня был повар она со мной работала
начала работать но 35 лет назад в первом
моём офисе и проработала со мной 15 лет
Повар который в моих компаниях в офисе
кормила людей Я люблю людей хорошо
кормить и что при этом они время не
тратили и деньги поменьше тратили уходит
какие-то кафе потом через час приходит
половина отравилась на завтрак нум
понима и вот Наташа Её звали Я кстати
она заслуженная сотрудница была у меня
очень Я даже ей пенсию одно время платил
после она прекратила работать Даже так
вот она мне говорила так Владимир
Юрьевич отправляйте новых сотрудников
она ещё у меня работала до перфор меня
перфор 24 года назад появилась она у
меня начала 35 лет назад работать то
есть я ещ сам на интуиции нанимал и вот
тогда без шуток один из способов был
такой
говорила едят так и
работают у нас был всегда столовая там
ну в подвале или где-то она говорит
Владимир ивич новый сотрудник есть
скажите мне беру на заметку через 3 дня
присылайте мне его как вот он обед
кушает я вам скажу как будет работать
интересно в процентах шутки шутки но в
процентах 80 сходилось то что она
говорит я уверен что так поставлялись я
уверен что она ещё же женщина женское
чутьё она его кормит его и смотрит там
этот будет работать а это гово этот не
будет работать
на самом деле в этом проявляется на
самом деле очень много проявляется как
человек кушает то когда когда он с
начальником общается он как бы знаете
думает что сказать какую маску одеть и
когда он спустился в подвал покушать он
там расслабляется и ведёт себя как бы
как он-то это пережёвывает тарелки водит
уже все уже поели он сидит не будет
работать а этот пришёл поел добавку
попросил спасибо сказал побежал будет
работать бери гово Да это точно
а ещ интересную такую вещь Я заметил
что тоже хороше на заметку Наверное
бизнесменам
всем что когда ты находишь правильного
человека результат сразу же на следующий
день Я приведу пример Я в прошлом году
решил нанять стилиста Ну думаю я чело Да
я человек публичный пора заняться своим
стилем хватит ходить как понятно кто
нанял стилиста и по всем канонам он
такой чуть-чуть
человек похож на нетрадиционную
ориентацию Ну вот стилист вот стилист
весь такой модный весь это такое он мне
2 с по месяца пудри мозги Что вы хотите
выразить э своим внешним видом Что вы
хотите сказать этому
миру в чём экспрессия что вы это какой
материал Вы любите какой то с
короче форму там ой цвета гамма 2 с по
месяца А у меня был парень Он бизнесмен
он во Франции в Италии счёт одежду в
дорогих вот тех же отелье где бриони и
так далее он счёт под своим
брендом и он говорит что-то мне ваш
внешний мит не нравится давайте я Вас
приведу в порядок Ну давай приходит
просто При приехал в один день взял вот
такую кучу одежды бросил
мертер померил померил вот всё что мне
подошло по по размеру Так он говорит всё
оставляет я ушёл он берёт на пол
разложил брюки с там с майкой это
сфоткал капсулы и сделал штук 10-15 и
говорит смотрите э это носите только с
этим Это только с этим Это только с этим
и только Всё за один день полностью
поменял мой стиль Всё полностью просто
Принс купил одежду просил померил
составил капсулы сфоткал и говорит вот
так если хотите эти кроссовки носить то
они могут быть только с этим с этим Если
хотите выбирать такие брюки то к ним
нужно только вот это вот это и никак не
другое
всё беру за о день за о день ну поэтому
он шьёт одежду там где шьёт бриони а
этот за о день я вот поэтому говорю
ребята когда
нанимаете профессионал вот к вопросу не
теш себя
надеждами я столько раз убеждался если
он хороший крутой чувак облегчение очень
быстро наступает обычно в течение
нескольких часов уже чувствуешь Максимум
в течение нескольких дней поэто кто-то
говорит там вот уже там я нанял там 4
месяца назад директор по маркетингу
нанял Ну и как ему надо войти в
должность ещё ему надо войти в ситуацию
Ну понятно что директор по маркетингу
это не стилист ему действительно чуть
Нужно больше времени разобраться но это
точно не 4 месяца Я думаю дня два
конечно Ну да да нене когда правильно
нанимает советуем так если не чувствуешь
быстро облегчение сам или коллеги Всё
значит что-то не так Дада то что все эти
вот ожидания давай ещё недельку ещё
недельку это уже дорога не туда мы
сегодня поговорили об Америке об
менталитете русскоязычном
пространстве бизнесе Давай Давайте
вкратце поговорим вот смотрителе время
появилось очень много новых технологий
особенно касательно искусственного
интеллекта и у него реально с одной
стороны огромный разрушительный
потенциал с другой стороны Огромный
созидательный потенциал бено и
причём проблема искусственного
интеллекта наверное Я бы даже сказал не
его проблема А наша проблема заключается
в том что он начинает сильно влиять на
то как мы друг с другом начинаем
общаться потому что искусственный
интеллект он уже претендует на то чтобы
заменять людей во многих сферах
человеческой деятельности в бизнесе и
так далее более того это он теперь
меняет наше отношение к знаниям к
получению знаний к проверке знаний и так
далее И вообще стоит под вопрос а нужно
ли нам носить знания с собой в голове
если у тебя под рукой чат gpt ты набрал
и он тебе даёт ответы на всё и как бы
в ужасных сценариях Представляется что
мы таким образом превращаемся ВМБ таких
которого не надо
даже голову включать за тебя всё
продумано всё сказано и умнее ча ты как
бы и не станешь и Вопрос вот такого
плана вот как вообще э новые
технологии вило
взаимоотношений между
людьми очень такой глубокий вопрос
Особенно для меня потому что я на
отношения между людьми вообще смотрю
по-особому
Угу и лично моё мнение что мы с духовной
точки зрения деградируем
Угу под духовно Я не имею в виду религию
я эти вопросы никогда публично не
обсуждаю как и политику но я имею в виду
что есть материально есть противополож
Да это деградирует яма что к сожалению
искусственный интеллект будет этому
наверное
способствовать продолжению какой-то
деградации каких-то таких глубоких
душевных
качеств теперь сказать что мы все
превратимся в амп вот этой тревоги У
меня
нет то есть что он всех на заменит думаю
что многие люди останутся безра точно и
он будет выполнять грандиозное
количество работ роботы там компьютеры и
прочее но я например Видел один прогноз
например что вот сейчас чтобы быть
программистом надо там изучать какой-то
язык и надо как бы подстраиваться под
компьютер вот один из очень там
авторитетных экспертов предсказал что
лет через 15 будут миллионы
программистов которые будут
программировать на человеческом
языке и компьютеру при устраиваться под
человека а не человеку под компьютер Ну
то есть я что хочу сказать что
творческие профессии созидательные и
творческие будут всё равно востребованы
и будут очень всё больше и больше
цениться Поэтому я-то лично не
беспокоюсь что как бы то что там мы
делаем или я делаю будет ненужно но если
говорить о
человечестве я Не берусь прогнозировать
но думаю что очень большие потрясения
нас ждут в течение там следующих 25 лет
скажем там я на самом деле искусственным
интеллектом так увлекаюсь не
профессионал конечно но увлекаюсь И в
меру своей профессии тоже
Аа пытаюсь приспособить его для бизнеса
Но где где возможно Угу и пытаюсь понять
границы возможного в искусственном
интеллекте и вы знаете такая интересная
вещь сейчас вообще речь идёт о том что
Возможно ли сознание и самое интересное
уже даже зачатки сознания появляются у
искусственного интеллекта меня удивило
то что оказывается Как работает
искуственный интеллект там ну так целая
такая система фильтров это по сути как
раньше Т9 было в телефоне когда
компьютер отгадывали следующие буквы
телефон а потом когда ты набираешь он
отгадывает следующее слово потом начал
Более сложный вер
более сложной версии он начал отгадывать
следующее
предложение и вот таким образом начал
развиваться и самое интересное
что алгоритм построен таким образом вот
эти большие языковые модели что
оказывается сейчас создатели не могут
предсказать что из него выйдет есть
многие большие языковые модели построены
по принципу ного ящика есть вхо одну и
даже создатели не знают что будет на
выходе потому что в машине столько
вариантов из сценариев
внутри что создатели не знает Вот как с
альтман в своём интервью сказал говорит
ему журналист задал вопрос а вы
сознательно вбили
возможность чату gpt программировать он
говорит Вы знаете Это было то что мы не
предсказать онм
программировать вот этот Побочный эффект
то что я называю эмерджентные свойство и
вот учитывая то что На каком уровне Я
считаю это ещё на зачаточном уровне
следующий уровень искусственного
интеллекта это будет agi это следующий
уровень А ещё будет ще три-четыре уровня
прогнозируется вот ближайшие там 6-7 лет
а то в какой-то момент я боюсь знаете
одного понятно что всю рутину все
повторяющиеся операции все рутинные
операции
искуственный интеллект можешь забрать
роботы могут забрать и так далее и так
далее я больше боюсь даже не то что мы
останемся без работы Пускай как мне
понравилось женщина вообще практичное
существо одна женщина вообще очень
классно высказалась для меня это вообще
классика она сказала так что вы мне
говорит мозги пудри что искусственный
интеллект может рисовать писать стихи
писать песни говорит лучше чем люди
нафиг говорит мне нужен такой
искусственный интеллект и роботы
искусственный интеллект и роботы чтобы
они стирали мыли посуду и дом убирали а
рисовать картины и писать стихи Я хочу
сама то есть мы начали не с того
искусственный интеллект начал рисовать и
писать А когда он должен начать убирать
гладить и так далее так вот м я уверен
искусственный интеллект и роботы дойдут
до этого то есть уберут все
повторяющиеся операции все рутинные
операции все грязные работы и так далее
и так далее И я за это не боюсь Угу но
но я вижу две основные проблемы первая
большая проблема в том что
а люди лишаются
смысла ведь выживание - это величайший
смысл Угу то
есть бедность нищета голод холод война
нам давали сильнейший Вектор развития Мы
понимали В какую сторону развиваться
чтобы этого не было да Мы понимали что
делать а теперь когда у нас голода
холода нет нету там войн дай Бог тоже не
будет что делать что делать и вот здесь
экзистенциальный такой возникает вопрос
большинство людей потеряет смысл вот я
читал исследование одного банка крупно
он говорил что самый большой
зарождающийся тренд - это mental
Wellness mental Wellness ментальное
благополучие Если Вы заметили сейчас
куча психологов и так далее Откуда их
появляется ВС больше и больше потому что
спрос есть а спрос Откуда появляется
Потому что люди теряют смысл
жизни это вот это такое Я считаю самый
большой вопрос потому что в конечном
итоге значение имеет только
смыслообразования имеет наша жизнь смысл
или нет А почему вы думаете что у них
пропадёт смысл выживать вы думаете что
будет так много блага
распределяться Так что людям которых нет
работы ВС равно будет хватать на что
жить проблема в том что если человеку Да
достаточно ресурсов кто ему даст дело
то смотрите мы сейчас многие государства
провели эксперименты по поводу
безусловного базового дохода смотрите
Когда роботы искусственный интеллект
забирают рабочие места то Человеку нужно
обеспечить доход потому если человека
Нет дохода не потребляет ничего не
потребляет экономика не растёт Угу то
есть ему надо каким-то образом эти
деньги дать Угу если ему просто так дать
то он деградирует деградирует точно да
соответственно и поэтому государство
сейчас проводит эксперименты давая
безусловный базовый доход Давай Им
просто так Ну ничего хорошего ник чему
хорошему этому не Приве нарушает
глобальный принцип да А теперь вопрос
как людям Дать деньги понятно Понял да и
это вот этот большой вопрос да да Если
давать людям благо без денег
то вообще смысл пропадает тогда и деньги
не нужны и блага не нужны и так далее А
для чего мы живём Что такое успех А в
чём он заключается А для чего я живу
вообще тогда А в чём что я как животное
поел покакал там
поразмять сильно потому что тоже смысла
нет то есть я вижу что
смыслообразование теряет вот
искусственный интеллект Т по смыс
духовной деградацией она будет
усиливаться Я согласен с тем что
искуственный интеллект - это как
катализатор выступа я в этом плане
абсолютно согласен с илоном
мас что пора колонизировать Луну или
Марс но я бы начал Сначала с очистки
Тихого океана потому что там километры
километры мусора то или соседнего села Я
бы начал бы
сначала тако больша человече
идея что довести до идеала нашу Землю
просто чтобы из неё сделать конфетку а
потом уже покорять Марс Луну и так далее
но Вопрос не в этом вопрос в том что
человечество нуждается сейчас в большом
смысле должен быть какой-то большой
созидательный объединяющий всех
смысл и это опять Как как Контр для того
чтобы вот эту всю дурную энергию
направлять в правильное русло и людскую
и искусственный интеллект
Вот то есть я вижу первую опасность в
том что искусственный интеллект и роботы
могут забрать смысл нашего
существования оставив нашу физическую
оболочку Наше тело А смысл забрав Смысл
А
второе второе опасение это то что
искусственный интеллект если а мы идём к
тому что вот сейчас уже Huawei создала
фабрику при котором роботы создают
роботов если мым
этого к этому придём то в какой-то
момент этот искусственный интеллект
который работает по принципу чёрного
ящика может сам подумать А нафига мне
эти кожаные мешки мы с вами Да они
неэффективны Они прокрастинирую они не
мотивирую они жрут много Пьют много
совершают ошибки косячат постоянно и так
далее мы становимся неэффективными по
отношению к ним и с точки зрения
рациональной и эффективной логики их Мы
точно лишнее
звено и мы таким образом Чем круче мы их
прокачаем Тем больше мы им даём повода
уничтожить нас ну есть такая точка
зрения Да но с другой стороны это как
чуть-чуть организация по гово мышление
собственника люди
инструменты мы всё-таки это мышление
собственника как бы без нас всё это Не
сработает одни Роботы как бы ну конечно
они могут что-нибудь Что называется
замутить если их вы на определённый
уровень но я что-то в них честно говоря
большой опасности проблема Проблема в
том что вот искуственный интеллект
недаром многие мыслители сейчас
сравнивают по уровню что это изобретение
круче ядерной бомбы конечно И опаснее
кстати говоря опаснее и ма тоже самое
сказал потому что искусственный
интеллект может вот смотрите мы сейчас
ещё на пороге создания квантового
компьютера китайцы Вот например
Google предквалификация
[аплодисменты]
и во время пресс-релиза сказали что мы
ещё сделали скачок и сделали теперь за
86 секунд мы вычисляем то что
Современный компьютер вычисляет за
10.000 лет то есть мы стремительно
движемся к созданию квантового
компьютера а это так называемое
квантовое превосходство и та нация
которая создат квантовый компьютер и
однозначно это делается для чего для
того чтобы ещё искусственный интеллект
на м
работал то что прозой ели вы
за 8 секунд производит вычисление
которые современные компьютеры делат 10
лет это значит в мире не останется ни
одного пароля который может выдержать
против квантового
компьютера Это значит что искусственный
интеллект будет иметь доступ к любой
атомной ядерной станции к любому
самолёту к любому электронному гаджету
минуя все
пароли стате что него вло
думать о противоядие всегда о рубильники
каком-то конечно да о Руби надо думать
всегда о
рубини сложность Да здесь здесь вот вот
эта проблема есть Ну вот я потому что
искусственный интеллект Он имеет
свойство быть
децентрализованным он же сейчас может
находиться во всех компьютерах мира
одновременно как на блокчейне и
соответственно чей рубильник это надо
договориться всему человечеству
одновременно вырубить компьютеры
невозможно да ну да но при этом я вот
могу сказать что я сам не
профессионально этим занимаюсь тоже
конечно пользуюсь этим чатом GP а
профессионалом с одним я общаюсь с
Казахстана Он мне помогает вот в
перформер и вот мы пытаемся его научить
отвечать на вопросы в соответствии с
технологие с нашей не получается Он
постоянно что-то какую-то хрень
прилетает какую-нибудь такую якобы
общепринятую Но на самом деле которая
неправильная То есть даже такую
элементарную задачу пока решить не
удаётся Ну это пока пока Дада скоро
удастся дадада понятно понятно Это я
считаю вопрос года два да да Безусловно
безусловно Да вот сейчас
осенью Open они планируют выкатить новую
верю это вообще будет бомба И я кстати
говоря вот хотел после на просто тако
пообщаемся с вами сыграем ещ в гольф
полететь в
и я задавал чату gpt вопрос есть ли
прямой рейс из того города где я живу
в есть и называет сколько лететь Мы
заходим на Google Flight покупать билеты
нету прямого рейса То есть он
иногда ну с точностью иногда там есть
вопрос но я например
[музыка]
маршрут двухнедельный март помери
я только с искуственным интеллектом
такие вопросы решаю 10 дней мне мозги
пудри Я за 10 минут решил Мы тоже с
женой в тениси летали Я у него спросил
какие лучши водопады какие это лучше
куда я м прямо говорю Составь маршрут
потом прямо поминутно поминутно плюс
учти расстояние учти пробки он всё мне
этого делает Ну да Так что есть плюсы
есть минусы но от нас зависит насколько
мы
сможем как бы минимизировать риски они
точно есть но то как люди себя ведут
если пос в обществе и на это общество и
туда в русскоязычную часть но большой
надежды нету что мы разумна в том-то и
дело на на надежды мало знаете проблема
человечества в чём заключается я это
называю проблемой
парламента
[музыка]
или можно ещё назвать проблемой кабмина
вот когда я общаешся с каждым отдельным
чиновником это эрудированный очень
грамотный логи честный и порядочный
челок
вме это какое-то непонятно
стадо они принимают какие-то абсурдные
решения И вот я боюсь что мы Как
человечество страдаем именно этим каждый
отдельный индивид умный но в целом Мы
принимаем решения какие-то
неадекватные Ну это да это хорошая
большая тема может быть на
говорили Владя Спасибо большое за эту
беседу Я очень рад что вы прилетели в
Америке У нас у этой беседы не было
конкретной цели А и не было точки А и
точки бло пообщаться вопрос я всегда во
главу угла ставил такое понятие как
ценность человеческого общения и мне
очень часто не хватает просто общения
хорошего собеседника говорить на любые
там важные темы не о каких-то бытовых
вопросах и так далее и Вот это Сегодня у
нас одна из таких встреч поэтому я
надеюсь этот формат тоже найдёт своего
слушателя понятно он не каждому залетит
не каждому пойдёт Но я уверен из
сегодняшней беседы наши слушатели
получат много пользы и как минимум это
затравку или пищу для своего размышления
А я желаю чтобы у вас эта рубрика
развивалась что у вас было много
интересных собеседников на разные темы
но судя по тому насколько интересны вы
сам спасибо Так что я уверен что у вас
эта рубрика будет иметь успех и у вас
будет очень много интересных собесед
Большое спасибо за Спасибо большое Всем
пока